you ready 1 2 3
I missed LHC stands for the Large Hadron
Collider which is this amazing particle
accelerator out there in Switzerland so
it's up and running again beams going
around one direction beams going around
another direction so Large Hadron
Collider is something that collides
Hadron sorta hard runs hard runs are
basically sub atomic particles a hadron
is a particle which contains quarks and
that's it that it undergoes what's known
as the strong force strong interactions
there are sort of fundamentally two
types of particles in the universe there
are head drums and leptons so hadrons
are the ones made up of quarks which you
may have heard of these very fundamental
particles of material and so they're
things like protons and neutrons the
things that make up normal material are
made up of quarks the LHC is simply the
Large Hadron Collider and it does
exactly what it says on the tin it's all
about crashing hydrants into each other
and so this is a real boy toy this is
all about taking two things again bang
and watching them fall apart and seeing
what's inside
it's a 27 kilometer ring around which
they send protons these are objects that
you and I are made of they make up the
core of our nuclei the whole game in
particle physics is to figure out the
properties that the fundamental
properties of matter and that almost
always involves going to discover more
and more massive particles we know about
the lower mass particles and we're
trying to learn about the more and more
massive particles because of the most
famous equation in the world e equals MC
squared you can actually create a
massive particle M by having lots of e
lots of energy so if you smash things
together with enough energy you can
actually turn that energy into mass and
so the whole game in particle physics is
cranking your particle accelerators up
to higher and higher energies and so you
can actually probe more and more massive
particles generate more and more massive
particles the way this pub this thing
works is by smashing protons into each
other and the file many billions of them
around
one direction and many billions of them
around in the other direction they
accelerate them so that they reach
almost at the speed of light in fact
they reach sir close to the speed of
light I was working this out earlier
today that they're only off the speed of
light by about the speed of Usain Bolt
about ten meters per second they get so
close to the speed of light and when you
smash these protons into each other you
create a whole shower of different
particles but the point is that the most
massive particles you can create get
bigger and bigger as the energy of those
proton beams get higher and higher
essentially what the Large Hadron
Collider is is a very large hammer right
and it's just exactly the same
experiment that we've all been doing
since we were three years old and
actually I've bought that experiment
with me today here it is this is an
experiment I first did as a child the
idea is that all the mass in these
particles smushed together and then the
all that mass gets created into energy
which then gets redistributed into a
whole series of new particles you're
looking to see what sort of ways these
energy can come out and there are lots
of known processes that you know about
because it produces quarks or it
produces some other debris coming out
gluons or whatever and after that there
is now the possibility that once in a
blue moon a very rare event will occur
where you'll see the traces of particle
have not seen before the Higgs boson and
if you see that it comes out with a
particular characteristic feature it's
not a process that's been seen before so
you're looking in all this debris of all
the known events for a little signal for
that particular thing which is rather
like looking for a needle in the
haystack and because the energies are so
high the hope is that they'll be able to
create particles with a loud with the
kind of masses that existed in the very
early universe about a billionth of a
second after the beginning of the
universe and these particles have become
famous already I mean even though
they've not been discovered the Higgs
particles supersymmetric particles dark
matter particles what we're going to do
is we're going to have a look and see
precisely what is going on in
side.this toys hot rod here okay so
first of all we're going to need some
safety equipment I have absolutely no
idea if this is going to work it worked
when I was three
you might just imagine they'll
reassemble back into the protons that
they were formed from but in actual fact
there are so many different ways that
you can redistribute this energy that
it's it's highly unlikely that they'll
reassemble back into this very
particular shape of the protons and then
moving the energy gets redistributed in
all different directions and so you'd
need to bring all this energy back
if you're going to reconstitute the
protons and you can't do that the Large
Hadron Collider is in the news now
because it's being switched back on
again so the story was it was switched
on with a big fanfare a little over a
year ago worked for a very little while
and then it had a very serious
engineering failure one two three the
way this thing works is you accelerate
these particles up to a huge speeds and
in order to do that you need enormous
magnetic fields very very large magnetic
fields the only way we can generate
those very large magnetic fields is with
these things called superconductors
superconducting magnets and in order to
get a superconducting magnet to work you
need to cool it down to very very low
temperatures so these things are cooled
down with liquid helium to just a couple
of degrees above absolute zero so
they're very very cold but you've got
this rather dangerous combination of
tons and tons I think there's about a
hundred tons of liquid helium in the
whole Large Hadron Collider so you've
got a hundred tons of liquid helium
which is you know very cold and quite
dangerous stuff and very very strong
magnetic fields which are literally
trying to pull the entire structure of
the Large Hadron Collider apart as well
as accelerating these particles around
because you know the different magnets
that make up there like the LHC will
attract each other just like normal bar
magnets do and unfortunately this
combination of things proved to be too
much there was a big failure but
basically one of these mirrors of one of
these magnets just collapsed under the
strain it was under and in the process
ended up dumping about a ton of this
liquid helium so almost sort of swimming
pools worth of liquid helium out all
over the tunnel we try it again
right one two
okay so there it is with one of the
fundamental difficulties or problems
with physics and in the 21st century is
trying to bring together quantum
mechanics and gravity and so the one of
the ways of trying to do this is via
something called the Higgs boson
so it's this the Higgs boson that is the
particle effectively that gives things
mass what the Large Hadron Collider is
really all about is finding this god
particle the Higgs boson okay now the
Higgs boson is what's going to explain
to us where mass comes from so we go
through our field of debris in our
collision and we pick out the one thing
the Higgs boson when we try to describe
nature when we try to describe the
forces of nature we have a model we have
a mathematical model in which we find
there are these particles present and
one of them happens to be the Higgs
particle it's the particle that will
give masses to objects in the university
to other particles in the universe but
there are other property other particles
that have been predicted that we believe
should be there because there are other
symmetries present in the universe that
are in these models or we hope these
symmetries are there one of them is
called supersymmetry
it's tough one because if you're a
particle physicist you'll say actually
you know this is a really exciting
experiment and even if it finds nothing
at all that's very exciting because that
rules out lots of things that we
currently think might be the way the
universe works what I'm not a particle
physicist you know and so actually I
want to see a result and if I if it ends
up producing a result and says you know
here's the Higgs boson here's what its
mass is here's what its properties are
and he's learned something else about
why the universe works then I'll get
very excited about it if at the end of
its lifetime they basically say what
we've excited done all this exciting
science and found nothing very much then
I will be less excited about it so it's
at that point of discovery in you know
that if they do find something it will
be brilliant as far as I'm concerned if
they don't find anything you're really
going to have to talk to to someone
who's a real specialist in the area
who'll be able to tell you why it's
still exciting it's a so it's a
multi-billion pound project it's
probably the single most expensive
engineering project that's ever been
it's certainly the single most expensive
physics project there's ever been
and so you know one of the obvious
questions is is it worth spending this
kind of money on these kinds of things
and it's a tough one to answer
especially in current economic climate
as to whether it really is I guess
there's a couple of answers one is that
you know fundamentally the whole human
endeavor has been about finding out more
about our surroundings more about the
universe and this is really just the
next step of that but the other thing
that you really have to give the
particle physicists credit for is of
course they're they're famous for though
they should be more famous than they are
but that one of the things that they
should be most famous for is one of the
biggest spin-offs that ever been from an
experiment which is that it was particle
physics physicists who are entirely
responsible for the world wide web in
their earlier experiments when they were
when they were doing basically the same
kind of things but rather lower energies
in order to communicate their results
around all the particle physicists to
make sure everyone was up to speed they
invented this thing the world wide web
for disseminating their results around
their colleagues and everything we've
seen the hundreds of billions of pounds
a year that the Internet is now worth to
industry all comes out of those particle
physicists messing around so if you ask
all they value for money I think it's
hard to argue against the idea that
actually they paid for themselves many
times over and they should have their
new experiment